hello and welcome to footnotes
as per usual i'm here to recap the most
ravishing ideas from around wired
today we're talking about all manner of
sprites that don't boss me around about
obeying my thirst you can't tell me what
to do
missy this came up in a game life story
about a dad hacking
donkey kong for his daughter so mario
gets kidnapped instead of pauline
which is more realistic anyway because
apes go crazy for a good
mustache in video games a sprite is a
small two-dimensional object
moving around in a larger scene such as
the barrels of beer that donkey kong
throws at pauline
but pauline is like you i prefer whiskey
these digital sprites take their name
from the sprites of folklore which
include fairies and elves and other such
products of nyquil overdoses
the term sprite more generally includes
ghosts but i'm going to focus on elves
and fairies
because this jerk has been bothering me
all week
so the classic image of the fairy is a
tiny winged creature
but fairies were originally human-sized
and lacked wings
so they could still fly especially
during tornadoes
and legend has it that of all things
iron can ward off fairies
like werewolves and silver and vampires
and garlic
and sarah palin and books this weakness
to iron is interesting in the case of
tinkerbell who for some reason chose
fixing pots and pans as a calling
probably because her parents made her go
to trade school for it and she's still
paying off student loans
as with tinkerbell fairies are generally
mischievous or even downright evil
in folklore they went so far as to steal
human babies
and replace them with their own
offspring known as changelings
so if your kid grows wings don't panic
have her clear the gutters
then admit to her that she's adopted
then have her change the ceiling lights
like fairies elves are often villainous
capable of poisoning livestock and
humans
not with too many cookies but with too
much death
and germans once believed elves cause
nightmares by sitting on your chest
which is easily and hilariously cured by
rolling onto your stomach
and when they're not too busy causing
nightmares or slaughtering people
elves for some reason enjoy ruining your
lawn by dancing in so-called
elf circles these are actually caused by
fungal growths
but various european tales say that
entering them will make you lose an eye
and that pee on them will give you a
venereal disease which is definitely the
least entertaining way to pick up
a venereal disease so ignore missile
never obey
your thirst
you